and guardian angels founder and WABC
radio host Curtis Sliwa also former
Republican candidate for New York city
mayor Curtis I don't know what kind of
an environment these lawmakers thought
they were walking into this morning but
they must have been pretty poorly
briefed by staff to willingly head into
the middle of that well I got to let you
know you're going to expect more of that
I'm the leader of the rebels I'm not the
politician who goes out and gives
speeches or the lawyers who go into
court to seek preliminary injunctions
against migrant centers we're going to
tie this city up a notch they've allowed
an illegal Invasion into our city our
state and our country politicians only
give speeches so you're seeing the Rage
of people and what AOC look at her on
her face AOC all out crazy Alexandria
ocasio-cortez who encourages this
Invasion who stopped Amazon from
providing good paying jobs to Americans
she's talking about the need for
illegals to work she was stunned because
in that crowd she saw moderate Democrats
not just Republicans in independent the
rage has spread and these elected
officials thought that we're all just
sheep sheep going
they can forget about that we're coming
after all of them every last one of them
who supports illegal aliens invading
America who we don't know we know
nothing about at the borders they're
going to pay a price at The Ballot Box
Curtis take a listen to a New York City
resident earlier today his name's David
got your response on the other side
I have family members waiting seven long
years in Colombia they filed legal
petitions what message are you sending
to the world break the law come we give
you everything free
when you talk about this Invasion at a
systemic level
who are you talking about specifically
we're talking about all those first
generation immigrants who had to wait
online as David said who a patiently
abiding by the rules many of whose
family members are still back in their
country of origin can you imagine how
they feel that all of these people that
we don't even know get to jump the queue
they haven't been vaccinated no medical
checks they haven't been invaded and
then our elected officials in sanctuary
states and cities by the way there are
no laws that say you're a sanctuary city
or state call ICE thugs demean them
won't let them cooperate with police and
the criminal justice system they bend
over backwards for the illegals and
expect us to suck a taxpayers to pay the
bill well it ain't happening anymore we
need ice we need border security we need
closed borders and we need to change the
political status of those who declare
Sanctuary cities and Sanctuary States
for illegals and meantime we have
veterans in the street mostly
african-americ Americans they live in
the parks in the Subways in the streets
many of them have emotionally disturbed
issues they get nothing they have to
show up at a cell sheltered as a curfew
illegal aliens there's no curfew they
get to smoke weed drink salvation
attacks players expense right up and
down the streets on motorbikes
Investments where did they get the money
for this Americans are outraged
Democrats Republicans and independents
and AOC she doesn't understand that
because the princess is never out in the
streets anymore she's up in the streets
Suites getting wine dined and pocket
lined
uh all right Curtis uh thanks for taking
time with us this afternoon we're going
to leave it there this is just the
beginning of many more actions to come
you watch hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else